يومكم واهلا بكم الى هذه الساعه الاخباريه
الجديده والتي نخصص معظمها لتطورات
الاحداث في السودان وهذه العناوين
الجيش السوداني يستهدف تمركزات دعم السريع
في محيط القصر الجمهوري واعمده دخان
تتصاعد في منطقه بحره
الشرطه السودانيه تنشر قوات من الاحتياط
المركزي في جنوب الخرطوم وام درمان
لمواجهه الانفلات الامنيه
وفي اخبارنا ايضا في هذه الساعه
روسيا تقول ان قرار الهجوم على
واشنطن وليس كييف وتتعهد بالرد
مقتلوا فتاه فلسطينيه برصاص قوات
اسرائيليه بزعم تنفيذ عمليه قطاع جنوبي
نابلس
[موسيقى]
تبادل الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
اليوم تبادلا الاتهامات بمهاجمه كل منهما
للاخر رغم هدنه جديده بدا سريانها اليوم
حيث تدور الاشتباكات في بحر ومحيط سلاح
المهندسين والاتحاد بالخرطوم هذا واظهرت
صور استهدافا جويا لتمركزات لدعم السريع
في محيط القصر الجمهوري والقياده العامه
بالخرطوم وافاد مراسل العربيه بان
الاشتباكات التي تدور هي الاعنف منذ بدء
الصراع منتصف الشهر الماضي اعرب الامين
العام للامم المتحده
عن اسفه لاخفاق المنظمه في وقف الحرب حيث
تقود المعارك المستمره جهود ترسيخ الهدنه
[موسيقى]
في الاثناء فدى مراسل العربيه بالدلاعي
معارك عنيفه في الخرطوم حيث دوت
الانفجارات منذ الصباح في محيط القصر
الجمهوري والقياده العامه للجيش مراسل
العربيه اكد ان الخرطوم تشهد اشتباكات هي
الاعنف منذ بدء الصراع هذا وتشهد العاصمه
تحليقا للطيران الحربي للجيش بشكل مكثف
اما فيوم درمان فتشهد المدينه اطلاقا
كثيفا لقذائف المدفعيه بين الجانبين
هذا ولم تتوقف الاتهامات المتبادله بخرق
الهدنه بين الجيش والدعم السريع وفي اخرها
اتهم بيان الدعم السريع قوات الجيش بشن
قصف عشوائي على عدد من مواقع تمركز قواتها
وبعض الاحياء السكنيه رغم الهدنه الجديده
التي بدا سريانها اليوم مؤكده على ان
القصف الذي شنه الجيش في المدافع
والطائرات يشكل تجاوزا للاعراف القوانين
الدوليه في المقابل اكد الجيش ان قوات
الدعم السريع حاولت الهجوم على قياده
منطقه بحر العسكريه واضاف الجيش السوداني
والنقواته دمرت عددا من العربات القتاليه
التابعه لدعم السريع وسلمت 5 اعرابات تم
تركها في ميدان المعركه
اظهرت لقطات جويه تصاعد دخان في المواقع
التي يعتقد ان قيادات للدعم السريع تتمركز
فيها في الخرطوم بحري مقابل القصر
الجمهوري وتحديدا في حي حله حمد والمنطقه
الصناعيه وحي الاملاك
[موسيقى]
في الاثناء نشر الجيش السوداني مقطعا
مصورا للمركبات والاسلحه تابعه لدعم
السريع بعد اشتباكاته الاخيره في محيط
السلاح الاشاره بالعاصمه السودانيه
بالخرطوم
[موسيقى]
القصر الجمهوري محور الاشتباكات الدائره
في الخرطوم يعتبر من اهم نقاط
الاستراتيجيه تجاذبا بين طرفي الصراع الذي
يعلن كل طرف منهما سيطره عليه التقرير
التالي يصلي الضوء على عمليات الاشتباك
الدائره في محيط القصر ومن يسيطر عليه
فعليا من مقر رسمي للرئيس ونوابه ومن
مضافه للرؤساء الاجانب تحول القصر
الجمهوري الجديد بالسودان الى بؤره رئيسيه
للسياحه فالقصر الجمهوري بات اكثر نقاط
اشتعالا الى جانب محيط القياده العامه
للجيش ومطار الخرطوم القصر مقره العاصمه
الخرطوم ويتكون من ثلاثه طوابق من يسيطر
فعليا عليه واين تدور الاشتباكات
هذا هو القصر هناك يتجاذب طرفات صراع
السيطره على الاقل اعلاميا قوه الدعم
السريع اعلنت سيطرتها على القصر قبل
اسبوعين لكن الجيش خرج مرارا لينفي ما
وصفه بالمعلومات المضلله والكاذبه غير ان
قوات الدعم السريع نشرت فيديو لعناصرها من
داخل القصر مؤكده بسطه سيطرتها عليه
ومؤكده كذلك احتفاظها بمواقع استراتيجيه
اخرى بينها مطار الخرطوم حاليا الاشتباكات
لا تزال مندلعه بين الطرفين بمحيط هذا
القصر لكنها تخطت المواجهات بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني فالاخير
استخدم قوات الشرطه الاحتياطيه من كافه
الولايات وهي ما وصفتها قوات الدعم السريع
بالقوه المقاتله والمعاديه وفي وقت يحاول
فيه الجيش وقوات الاحتياط تقدم نحو القصر
تحت غطاء جوي تتصدى قوات دعم باسلحه رشاشه
وبمضادات الطيران
نذهب الان الى الخرطوم ومعنى من هناك
مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي سالم مرحبا بك
معنا في هذه الساعه الاخباريه على العربيه
ما الذي جعل الامور تاخذ منحا تصاعديا حتى
اليوم حتى يوصف بانه الاعنف منذ بدا
للشبكات
نعم لم تهدا الامور اصلا منذ بدا هذه
الاشتباكات بل كانت في وتيره احيانا
متصاعده واحيانا منخفضه هذه واحده من
الايام التي تزادت فيها وتيره الاشتباكات
بعد فجر اليوم تزايدت هذه الوتيره وربما
ايضا المواجهات المباشره واحده من الامور
التي جعلت وتيره الاشتباكات تتزايد بعد
ذلك وتصبح في مناطق متفرقه كان ابرزها في
محيط القصر الرئاسي ومحيط القياده العامه
للجيش وكذلك في مدينه بحري في مناطق
متفرقه منها وكذلك مدينه ام درمان
سالم ماذا عن الوضع الانساني حتى اليوم
خصوصا في بعض المناطق هل في حلحله للازمه
في بعض المناطق
ما زالت هناك العديد من الاشكاليات فيما
يتعلق بالوضع الانساني خاصه المستشفيات
التي تعاني نقصا في الكوادر الطبيه ونقص
في المعينات الطبيه كذلك في العديد من
المستشفيات المتفرقه من العاصمه الخرطوم
يضاف اليها كذلك ما يتعلق بالامداد
الغذائي ايضا هنالك اشكال في بعض المحل
التجاريه في بعض السلع المدره كذلك في
مناطق متفرقه من العاصمه الخرطومه خاصه
المناطق القريبه من مناطق الاشتباكات
بالنسبه كذلك للوضع الاقتصادي ايضا يعاني
المواطلون في المناطق البعيده من المناطق
الاشتباكات من وضع اقتصادي يكاد يكون على
حافه الانهيار في ظل عدم توفر المال لديهم
وايضا توقف العديد من البنوك حتى
التطبيقات كذلك فيها بعض الاشكاليات في
تذبذب الخدمات كذلك تذبذب في التيار
الكهربائي في مناطق متفرقه هناك مناطق لم
يصل التيار الكهربائي منذ بدا هذه
الاشتباكات وكذلك الامداد المائي ايضا
بشكل كامل عادت الامور فيها الى مكان قبل
الخامس عشر من ابريل الماضي
الان في هذه اللحظات نستمع الى اصوات
مضادات الطائرات وتحليق للطائرات هنا في
مدينه الخرطوم وفي الجهه الشرقيه منها
تحديدا نستمع الى عزيزي الطائرات وكذلك
مضادات الطائرات التي تنطلق من محيط مطار
الخرطوم ومحيط القياده العامه للجيش في
هذه المنطقه تحديدا في هذه اللحظات
بالنسبه للمناطق التي تعد فيها هدوء نسبيه
بعيده عن مناطق المركز في المدن الثلاث
مركز بحري ومركز الخرطوم المناطق البعيده
من المناطق المركزيه يكون فيها هدوء نسبي
حركه فيها تبدو شبه طبيعيه والمواطنون
يواصلون فيها حياه اقرب للطبيعي طيب هل
رصدتم عمليات نزوح جديده من
السودانيه
هناك عمليه نزوح كانت قد بدات ووتيرتها
قلت كثيرا في الايام القليله الماضيه حتى
هذا اليوم وربما لان اغلب الذين كانوا
يريدون النزوح قد نجحوا بالفعل في مناطق
متفرقه من العاصمه الخرطوم ابرز مناطق
النزوح كانت في الاتجاهات الشرقيه
والشرقيه الجنوبيه وكذلك الجهات الشماليه
ولايه نهر النيل والشماليه ولايات الجزيره
القضارف حتى ولايه البحر الاحمر مدينه
بورسودان شكرا جزيلا لك من الخرطوم مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشميه
اعرب الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيريش عن اسفي لاخفاق المنظمه في وقف
الحرب في السودان حيث تقوض المعارك
المستمره جهود ترسيخ الهدنه قال غوتيرش ان
الامم المتحده فوجئت بتفجر العنف في
السودان ولم تتوقع تطور الاحداث بهذه
السرعه وشدد غوتيريش على ضروره التحرك
بصفه مستعجله ووقف كافه اشكال التصعيد
وايجاد حل يعيد السودان الى بر الامان
وسعي لتحقيق الاستقرار والوحده
هذا واظهرت صور اقمار صناعيه حريقا في
مطار الخرطوم الدولي مع استمرار المواجهات
[موسيقى]
وفي متابعه للتطورات الصحيه كشف الناطق
باسم اللجنه التمهيديه لنقابه اعتبار
السودان سيد محمد عبد الله عن توقف اكثر
من 67% من المستشفيات القريبه من مناطق
للشبكات عن الخدمه مشددا على ضروره اعاده
تشغيل هذه المستشفيات وايقاف الاشتباكات
في اقرب وقت ممكن
ان هناك اكثر من 67% من المستشفيات في
مناطق النزاع المتوقفه تماما عن الخدمه 89
من 88 مستشفى
يعمل منها فقط 29 بشكل
جزئي نحن نحرص على حياه الانسان نحاول مع
لجان المقاومه مع المتطوعين ومع الزملائنا
عن نعيد التشغيل هذه المستشفيات ولكن
القتال المستمر والقصف العشوائي وكل هذه
الاشياء تمنع ذلك للاسف
الكادر محدود لعدم تمكنه من الحركه الكادر
الطبي لا يستطيع المعينات الطبيه في تناقص
مستمر حتى الكهرباء والمياه
هذا واظهرت لقطات فيديو لمركبات اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في شوارع العاصمه
الخرطوم حيث تتفاقم الاوضاع الانسانيه
والطبيه جراء استمرار المواجهات
نذهب الى الخرطوم معنا من هناك الدكتور
محمد ابراهيم عبد الرحمن متحدث باسم وزاره
الصحه في السودان دكتور محمد مرحبا بكم
معنا في هذه الساعه نقابه اطباء السودان
تعلن توقف نحو 70% من المستشفيات قرب
مناطق للشبكات انتم في وزاره الصحه كيف
تقيمون الوضع الصحي والجسم الطبي في
السودان اذا
رسول الله
بانه السودان لا توجد به نقابه اطباء
السودان به القانون المنظم للنقبات عمال
السودان
2010 ينص على نقابه المهن الصحيه وهذه تم
حلها السودان من 2010 حتى الان لا توجد
نقابه اطباء في السودان نقابه المهن
الصحيه التي تم حلها منذ الثوره نعم محمد
في هذه المتاهات ولكن هذه معلومات يعني
صحيه
لاطباء ينقلون لنا جديد المعلومات
المعطيات من هذا
هم هم يتعايشون ويعيشون الواقع في
المستشفيات يعرفون ما هي المستلزمات التي
تفتقر اليها المستشفيات ماذا يحتاج انه
مرضى وللحقيقه والتاريخ لا توجد نقابه
اطباء
حدثني عن موقف وزاره الصحه طيب الان تفضل
كيف تقيمون الوضع الذي الذي ذكرها الاخ
السابق خيار غير دقيقه ما هو الرقم الذي
لديكم دكتور
هذه النسبه غير دقيقه وغير
النسبه يجب ان تكون من مجموع المستشفيات
التي توجد في الولايات الخرطوم
بكافه انواعها مستشفيات حكوميه مستشفيات
خاصه مستشفيات الجيش والشرطه والامن
والجامعات
من هذه الارقام تؤخذ النسبه هذه النسبه
مضلله مضلله للرائي العالمي ومضلل للرائي
المحلي الدكتور محمد طيب عدد الاصابات
تفضل الان عدد الاصابات 3,02 اصابه في
الغطائين العام الخاص الوفيات 207 حاله
وفاه في الغطاء عين العام والخاص وهذه
موثقه اما بتحويل الى المشرحه وشهادات
الوفاه هذه من واقع السجلات الطبيه
والارقام الاحصائيه من المؤسسات الصحيه
لدينا في عدد
يتحدثون عن جثث ما زالت ملقاه في الشوارع
لا يتمكن ولا تتمكن سيارات الاسعاف من
الوصول اليها
على الشارع
وهذه الجثث من قبل عشره ايام توجيه من
القياده في الدوله في كل المناطق التي
اهدا هدات فيها الاشتباكات تقوم الجهاد
المعنيه بايجاد جثث الى المشارح
والتعامل معها ويبقى الاجراءات المعتمده
لدى الجهات العدليه
مجموع العمليات مجموعه العمليات 553 عمليه
كبرى لاستخراج الاعين الناريه
من اجزاء متفرقه من الجسم هذه الارقام لا
تحتوي على او لا تضم العمليات الاجله
والعمليات الطارئه بالنسبه للامراض
المزمنه هذه ارقام
اصابات الحرب
بالنسبه لعدد المستشفيات في ولايه خرطوم
يوجد 134 مستشفى عام يتبع للغطاء العام
والقطاع الخاص هذه المستشفيات موزعه على
السبع محليات التي تشكلات الخرطوم
الذي يعمل فيها منها
93 مستشفى بخروج عدد اثنين مستشفى اليوم
مستشفى حاجه صافي والتي تمركز حولها قوات
الدعم السريع ومستشفى الولاده ام درمان
والتي تمركز حولها قوات الدعم السريعه
صباح اليوم وبالتالي هذه
من الخدمه اصبح العدد الذي يقدم من
المستشفيات التي يقدم الخدمه حتى صباح
اليوم 93 مستشار من اصل 134 مستشفى تحت
وصايه او اداره وزاره الصحه هنالك حداشه
المستشفى يدعون للجيش والشرطه والامر
والجامعات تقدم الخدمات
المستشفى غير مشموله في 134 مستشفى
اما المراكز الصحيه المرجعيه والتي تراجع
الحالات المزمنه
51 مركز صحي مرجعي يقدم الخدمه على مستوى
الاختصاصي من مجمل 81 مركز هنالك مراكز
غسيل الكلى وهذه مهمه جدا طالما اربه
وزاره هي الجهه المعنيه والمسؤوله
والمنوطه بتقديم كل ما يلزم من الجانب
الصحي يعني كدوله السودان للمواطنين
وخصوصا في هذه الظروف الصعبه ماذا قامت
بالعمل به وزاره الصحه لكي تتواصل مع كافه
الاطراف وتوفير الممرات الامنه التي يطالب
بها كل الاطباء في المستشفيات وحتى ايضا
العاملين في سيارات الاسعاف للوصول الى
المحتاجين
اختي الكريمه هنالك لجنه عليا تضم كافه
الوزراء المعنيين الاتحادين المعنيين
والولاء المعنيين او
ممثلين لمجلس السياده هم يقولون يقولون
بهذا العمل بالجهاز وتصلها
في توفير ممرات امنه
في في ايصال
توفير الامداد الكهربائي الامداد المائي
والوقود وهكذا طيب انا اشكرك على مستويات
من المستوى الاعلى وحتى مستويات الغرفه
المركزيه في المستشفيات انا اشكرك جزيل
الشكر من الخرطومه الدكتور محمد ابراهيم
عبد الرحمن متحدث باسم وزاره الصحه في
السودان
هذا وتتواصل عمليه نزوح حيث يواصل مئات
السودانيين نزوحهم نحو مصر فرينه من
المعارك المستمره بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع وفي الايام الماضيه
شهدت المعابر البريه الجنوبيه بين مصر
والسودان تزاحما شديدا لعبور عشرات
الحافلات التي تقل السودانيين والاجانب
المقيمين بالبلاد الى مصر
على حسن الاداء والضيافه والمعامله ولكن
في بعض النواقص يشير اليها تكدس عالي جدا
يحتاج الى خدمات اسرع الناس جايه بتنشن
عالي جدا بمنك حاله بتاعه حرب فرجاء
يعني مناوله ومداوله الامر باسرع في تقدس
كثير في حلفا بهدي المشكله حاسب يتقابل
بتقابل
يعني اعتمر عالغينهم العالقين بجمهوريه
يعني جمهوريه مصر العربيه هم قاعدين نحسب
حلفا يعني شغال من السودان برفع مواطنين
من المعبره بالسوداني لابو سمبل
الحركه شويه اليومين دي يعني صعبه يعني مع
الحروبات والمشاكل
يشكل استمرار القتال في السودان وتدفق
الاف الفرينه الى دول الجوار ومن بينها
مصر ضغوطا على اقتصاد البلاد وعلى امنها
القومي خصوصا وان تبعات الحرب الروسيه
والاوكرانيه تزال تلقي بظلالها على مصر
بحسب مراقبنا
الاف السودانيين يتدفقون يوميا عبر
المعابر البريه مع مصر هربا من القتال في
بلدانهم تدفق يثير مخاوف السلطات المصريه
بسبب التاثيرات السلبيه المتوقعه على
اقتصاد البلاد الذي يعاني بالفعل من تبعات
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه بالاضافه
لاستضافه مصر لملايين اللاجئين من دول
عربيه خلال الاعوام الماضيه في دعم دولي
لهذا الموضوع عشان خاطر نقدر ان احنا
نتحمل ولا سيما ان احنا عندنا فوق الخمسه
مليون سوداني موجودين بالفعل واجمالي زي
ما سارى سياده الرئيس اجمالي اللي موجودين
اللاجئين يفوق 9 مليون الوضع على الحدود
اثر بالفعل على حركه تنقل البضائع بين
البلدين عشرات الناقلات تعجز عن المرور في
الاتجاهين
25 يوم
وطبعا الخسائر دي ان العربيه واقفه وانا
واقف وصاحب البضاعه مش عاوز يقول ارجع على
اساس ان الحال يتصالح ونخش فانا طبعا ما
هوش هنخش مستحيل ان احنا هنخش بعد الضرب
ده وبعيدا عن الاقتصاد فان كثيرين يحذرون
من تداعيات استمرار المواجهات في السودان
وزياده اعداد النازحين على الامن القومي
المصري فهناك خشيه من محاولات استغلال
الفوضى لتسلل عناصر من الجماعات المتطرفه
لدخول الاراضي المصريه في حدود مفتوحه مع
ليبيا وبالتالي ممكن ان يكون هذا ممر
للعناصر الارهابيه وعناصر القريبه المنظمه
دائما ما ترتبط الارهاب بعناصر الجريمه
المنظمه العناصر بيبقى بيوفروا الدعم
اللازم سواء المادي او المعنوي او
اللوجستي للعناصر الارهابيه وبالتالي هذه
العناصر دي بتلاقي في الحاله بتلاقي فيه
ملاذ امن القاهره مستمره في العمل مع
شركائها الاقليميين والدوليين في محاوله
لوقف القتال وتثبيت الهدن وعوده الاستقرار
للسودان وتبقى الامال معقوده على نجاح
مبادرات الدوليه والاقليميه في اقناع طرفي
النزاع في وقف الاقتتال حتى لا تتفاقم
الاثار السلبيه على جميع دول الجوار احمد
عثمان العربيه من معبر ارجيل على الحدود
المصريه السودانيه
نذهب الان الى حيث تسببت المواجهات
المسلحه بين الجيش والدعم السريع في توقف
حركه الاف من شاحنات نقل البضائع من
الميناء الرئيسي في بورتسودان الى مختلف
الولايات السودانيه فيما يتخوف اصحاب
الشاحنات التي تحمل الامداداتنا القمح
والوقود والمواد الاساسيه من اطاله امد
هذا الصراع
المواجهات المسلحه القت بظلال سلبيه على
قطاعات حيويه ومهمه في البلاد هنا في شرق
السودان تبرز معاناه سائق الشاحنات
المتوقفين عن العمل كواحده من تداعيات
الاوضاع الامنيه في السودان
والله المشكله انه العربات دي شاحنه وطبعا
الوضع وما قادرين نتحركوا يعني عندنا
عربات قميص طلعت
اول نقطه بتاعت عبور ونرجعها على اساس
البلد ما في عمل
دي اكبر مشكله
رمضان لغايه الان ما قادرين تتحرك هو
عربات شحن وقاعده بس
زي ما شايفين الحديده اهو شاحن واقف والله
شاحنين سكر شاحنين دقيق
وحدين ماشيين الخرطوم وواحدين ماشيين
بولايه البحر الاحمر طالبها وتتحدث عن
خسائر باهظه كمرحين اصحاب شاحنات
تقريبا متوقفه نسبه 90% او زياده يعني هذا
من جانب اما بقيه الملفات الخدميه
والتنمويه فان السلطات في ولايه البحر
الاحمر تؤكد العمل على استقرار الاوضاع
والتعاطي بايجابيه مع قضيه اجلاء رعايه
دول الاجنبيه الوضع الامني بصفه عامه على
مستوى العشره
محلياتهم يعكر صوف الامن في هذه الولايه
يمكن الحياه تصير بصوره طبيعيه كما
شاهدتموها ايضا الاسواق النشاط التجاري
بصوره ممتازه الحياه بصوره طبيعيه ما شاء
الله ما عندنا مشاكل اياميه
يمكن بالاخوه
العالقين حتى ما غادروا السودان نحن عن
طريق التنسيق مع منظمات المجتمع المدني
والاخوه الخيرين فيما يدبر سوداني الان تم
اعداد ما يقارب سبعه مناطق تقدم فيها كل
الخدمات مما شربها وجبات يمكن الثلاثه
وجبات لم تقدم من هؤل الاخوه
والبرنامج بصوره ممتازه جدا نزار البداوي
لقناتي العربيه والحدث من مدينه بورسودان
شرقي السودان
يبقى معنى نزار بقداوي من بورتسودان نزار
مرحبا بك معنا في هذه الساعه الاخباريه هل
اصبحت بورتسودان نافذه المساعدات
الانسانيه هذه المره
بالفعل مدينه بورسودان حاضره ولايه البحر
الاحمر على ساحل البحر الاحمر في شرق
السودان اصبحت نافذه مهمه واستراتيجيه
لاجلال رعايه دول الاجنبيه ولوصول
المساعدات الانسانيه هذا الحديث اكده يوم
الامس ممثل الامين العام للامم المتحده في
السودان رئيس بعثه يونيتامس واكده ايضا
وكيل الامين العام للامم المتحده مارتن
جرافيث الذي قضى ساعات يوم الامس هنا في
مدينه بورسودان الان هذا هو المطار
الرئيسي في مدينه بورسودان اسبوعان كامله
مره على اول عمليه اجلاء جوي اقلعت من هذا
المطار الذي ما زال يواصل في استقبال من
يطالبون بالاجلاء اكثر من 85 رحله جويه
استقبلها هذا المطار واقلعت عشرات
الطائرات من هذا المطار الى مختلف الوجهات
الدوليه والاقليميه والعربيه والاوروبيه
هذه الصور التي تشاهدونها الان هي لعدد من
السودانيين وايضا لمن يحملون الجنسيه
الاستراليه الان في طريقهم لمغادره
الاراضي السودانيه عبر هذا المطار الذي
غادرت عبره خلال الصحافه الماضيه في هذا
اليوم اربع طائرات توجهت الى عدد من
المطارات في المنطقه وفي
الوجهات الدوليه والاوروبيه نحن الان ايضا
ننتظر بعد قليل في سياق الوضع الانساني او
وصول لجسر جوي من قبل دوله الكويت يضم نحو
طنا من المساعدات الطبيه والانسانيه ستصل
بعد قليل الى هذا المطار مطار بورسودان
بعد ان وصل يوم الامس كما ذكرنا مارتن
جريفيث الذي طالب بالتوفير ضمانات لوصول
المساعدات الطبيه والانسانيه وخلق ممرات
امنه لوصولها الى مختلف المتاثرين في
الخرطوم في دارفور في عدد من مناطق
السودان بالتالي الان الحديث والتاكيد على
ان بورسودان الان اصبحت معبر استراتيجيا
واصبحت نافذه مهمه لتلقي المساعدات
الانسانيه او الطبيه التي ستصل تباعا الى
هذه النقطه هنا في شرق السودان
انتظار بالحديث مع صحفيين وايضا شهود فيما
يتعلق بحجم الاحتياجات سواء مستلزمات طبيه
ومعيشيه وغيرها اذا ما تحدثنا عن احتياجات
في بورت سودان حيث تتوافد ويتدفق الالاف
لاجل عمليه الاجلاء ما هي حجم الاحتياجات
على صعيد الاحتياجات في عدد من المناطق
المتاثره فلنبدا بدار 4 بما ان بورسودان
الان هي نافذه لتلقي المساعدات فان
المساعدات ستاتي الى عدد من المناطق في
دارفور تحديدا الذين اتجهوا شرقا او غربا
نحو دوله تشاد معينات الايواء المستلزمات
الطبيه المعينات الصحيه الغذائيه
المياه الشوربه النظيفه توفير الامصال
الادويه كل هذه تبقى من المستلزمات المهمه
والحيويه هنا في شرق السودان
المجتمعات المحليه منظمات المجتمع المدني
تجتهد في توفير ما يلزم لاستضافه الذين
وصلوا الى شرق السودان لكن ايضا تبقى
الوضعيه الصحيه تحتاج الى دعم معينات
الايواء تحتاج الى دعم المستلزمات الطبيه
المرافق الصحيه تحتاج الى دعم دولي ودعم
اممي كما تعلمين بان القطاع الصحي في
السودان تاثرا مباشرا والاحداث الامنيه
القت بظلال سلبي على اهم القطاعات الحيويه
وهو القطاع الصحي بالتالي فان وصول اي سند
ودعم صحي ومعينات ومستلزمات طبيه وغذائيه
يمكن ان تعين ويمكن ان تساهم في تخفيف
وطات الاوضاع التي يعيشها ملايين
السودانيين وملايين من الذين تاثروا من
هذه الاحداث من مختلف الجنسيات التي ما
زالت تعيش هنا في السودان انا اشكرك جزيل
الشكر من بورتسودان مراسل العربيه نزار
بقداوي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات